The simplest test of genes in the environment is when we compare two sets of
identical twins. Those who are reared apart, and those who are reared together.
Because they're genetically identical, if genes played no role in personality,
then we'd see a very small correlation or similarity between twins who were
reared apart, so different environments. Likewise, if environment played no
role, we would see the same correlations between twins that were raised
together and those who were raised apart, regardless of where they were raised.
When researchers collected data on personality of relatives including identical
twins, they found evidence for about 50% of the differences in personality
stemming from genetic influence. So, about half of our personality differences
are due to our genetic make up. So, you would think that the other half stems
from the environment. And that's essentially true. But, it's not that simple.
We can look at environment in two ways. One that we share with our family and
one that we do not share with our family. So, friends, teachers, role models,
and more.